what's up my fellow geeks zacky here
from geek culture bringing you another
fantastic video this time we'll be
taking a look at the rog phone 5.
now we don't only have the phone but it
also comes with compatible accessories
such as this erective cooler as well as
the kunai 3 gamepad so let's go straight
to the video we'll be playing some games
on the asus rog phone 5. so in case if
y'all don't believe us
this is the asus rg phone five box you
can see here it's a number five over
here yeah
thank you asus sending this to us and
we're gonna actually check out a few
games both free and paid so let's go
ahead and start with call of duty
so let's hook up the cooler to the phone
on top of that let's go and double check
our graphics settings
audio and graphics
so
we could play a very high quality but we
won't actually reach the maximum
frame rate that we can go
and since this phone has 144 hertz we
want to hit max there we go and this
would take the graphic quality to high
for now
so let's go ahead and play a game
now you probably won't be able to see
the full 144 hertz youtube has only
output this at 4k 25 frames per second
but i'm really experiencing very smooth
gameplay
speakers are also very good yeah we're
at less than half percent
of volume
but it's it's really good and loud very
crisp as well
31 by 9 aspect ratio as well
really makes
a lot of difference when it comes to the
controls of the game especially when
you're doing touch screen
and i really enjoy the field of view
here
compared to the iphone
[Music]
all right and there you have it guys
that was call of duty mobile
so far so good
phone is
feeling nice and cool
with the error active cooler
so let's hop on to the next game
so right now we're playing pop g we
skipped ahead through the boring bits
we're gonna go to our settings
you can see on the graphics uh we've
played on smooth quality at extreme
frame rate which would give us about 120
hertz
of uh frame rate so let's go ahead and
play the game
so
all right we're gonna win that chicken
dinner so
it's great
so that's it for pubg let's move on to
the next game
so the next game what we have loaded is
great auto sport and we've also attached
the asus q93 gamepad now to answer some
of your questions does the aero active
cooler work with the kunai 3 gamepad
along with its case yes it does it's
actually cooling the phone right now
now what i want to do is to actually
check the optimization for
the phone so we get to choose energy
saver graphics and performance and we
want to get the best of the frame rates
here so let's go for performance
there we go very nice smooth gameplay
now
and i'm not very good at racing games
but hey
all right just to show you
what this phone can do
oh no
oh this is slick okay
[Music]
so it is quite surprising what
video games can do now or mobile video
games can do now
and grid is one of the most
um
graphics intensive games you can get out
in the
paid app market so
yeah i'm screwing this up a wee bit
there we go maybe this works better
[Applause]
[Music]
back out again
[Music]
[Applause]
now let's pause here for a sec
now i'm pretty sure with a phone like
this you also want to see
the
optimization for high graphics
so let's enable best graphics for this
game
now it is on 30 fps lock but
you can see the graphics has drastically
improved
yes
some first person view
[Music]
ah okay i can't do that
[Music]
and let's go out again
no still crashed
my audio is still
awesome on this phone
yeah so that's about it for our great
auto sport
and let's move on to the next game
all right so we just loaded up gangshin
impact
as you can see we're running at the high
frame rate mode
this is what it looks like
the graphics looks awesome there's light
rays
the lighting of this is wow
it actually looks pretty damn good
actually
reach at a setting so we can actually
show you the differences in graphics
performance this
is the lowest setting
it looks like it's 30 frames per second
it's all right
you get a little bit of jaggies there's
no
there's not much lighting or shaders
and let's
turn this
to
the highest quality settings
all right
[Music]
and wow okay that's also
60 fps
and oh golly
wow
it looks really good
so smooth
check out that frame rate damn
right
effects
and even the particles here let's try
and do this
it looks pretty neat
yeah
let's go outside for a little while
and so we can show you a little bit more
on the world
and you can just see the
viewscape
of the place
looks super neat
the game is very nice and responsive
and because of the aeroactive cooler
that we've attached the phone is still
nice and cool
even though the game is pretty much
overclocking the system right now it
still looks very nice and smooth
let's do some combat
[Music]
very nice
so yeah that's pretty much it for
gangster impact
very very awesome
wow
hey what's up guys danish here to take
over the gameplay for mobile legends
because zeki as guest isn't that very
good at this game let's go
try to keep up
if you can
try it
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
ah
the stars are my beacon
oh
you don't want to dance
[Laughter]
and last but not least we are running
dead cells as well
just check the options on the video
and we are running at no fps cap because
we want to get a full 144 hertz we also
have a high resolution pretty much
enabled everything else
just to maximize the power of the rg45
so let's go ahead and play the game
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's very fast loading times
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so you can see that after playing all of
those games that the rog 5 is really
really really awesome i mean you got
144hz display you can play almost
everything in ultra high frame rates so
you know you're getting the best of the
best with this phone now if playing all
those games in a higher setting does not
sway to get one for yourself then
perhaps the benchmark scores for
geekbench 5 until 2 and 3d mark might
entice you of course you're getting the
best of the best in terms of performance
and that means that comes in a premium
price starting from 799 euros and it
goes all the way up to 999 euros and
that all depends on your choice of
memory and ram of course do check out
the link in the description below for
more details and pricing of course do
check out the link in the description
below for more details as well as our
review and of course do let us know in
the comments what game you would like us
to play on the rog phone five and if you
enjoyed this video do give us a thumbs
up and if you haven't already do
consider subscribing and smash that
notification bell icon so you can stay
updated whenever we upload new videos
until then this is zeki signing off
thanks for watching
you